hallo mein name ist luca und es schneit
grad draußen und ich mag eigentlich kein
schnee obwohl ich schneeball twitter
gepostet habe aber mir ist jetzt kalt
wir spielen akinator mir wurde sie auf
die kommentare geschrieben dass ich sehr
oft gespielt wurde
das machen wir
currywurst mag ich übrigens auch gerne
wie komme ich im ausland schwachsinn ja
meine figur wurde durch youtube
navarro 3 das letzte war
leb deine figuren contractors immer ja
hat er nahm mit einer figur vier
buchstaben wer hat sich denn die frage
ausgedacht moment mal meine figur hat
vier buchstaben war bei wamu drei dabei
und gibt in meinem zimmer
wieso weißt du das jetzt noch nicht
meine begrüßung ist nicht meine figur
gehört nicht zur afis bande die bilder
die eingereicht werden werden noch immer
besser naja es ist kein crafter ich
wurde 3
wir haben 300 special ein 300.000
special nicht da ich 300.000 place of
akinator erreicht hat habe ich mir
gedacht ich hätte einen tag
das waren jetzt hoffentlich nicht meinem
tizen vom praktikum ein prost auf
300.000
es tut mir leid dass ich gefunden habe
ich dachte guckt mich jetzt nicht so an
bis ihr wart scheiß auf special
dass ich mir das wasser in die keller
ist leitungswasser und das steht da seit
drei wochen
wer jetzt besser als gute freunde
323.000 mal das ist ja super und zuletzt
vor drei minuten
das ist unheimlich ich weiß nicht wann
ich dieses video hochladen werde
allerdings
worauf sollte ich gerade hinaus durch
euer krasses worten bei tubes part 1 bin
ich zu 100
bei der zweiten folge auch noch dabei
und dann hat mich costas und dark
victory gefragt ob ich nicht doch hätte
die ihnen zu sagen was sie eventuell
reinpacken sollen dann habe ich gesagt
hey zerriss sich in den akinator ein
paar das heißt diese figur seht ihr und
judas folge zwei wenn dies nicht
komplett verpacken ich mache jetzt ein
neues muster und zwar mache ich jetzt ja
nein ich weiss nicht wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich nicht immer nacheinander
meine figur macht let's play smile
sag deine figur bei youtube am anfang
hallo mein name ist luca als weitere
frage
ich muss dazu glaube ich nichts mehr
sagen oder ich weiß nicht ob sie bei
wago drei damit spielten wahrscheinlich
warum zwei dabei sieht wird
wahrscheinlich kein gta 5 online-spiel
spielt deine figur bei teil 2 mit was
ist den nochmaligen ja nein ich weiss
nicht wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
nicht ja nein ich weiss nicht
wahrscheinlich scheint nicht ich denke
an den ritter der kokosnuss
den ritter der kokosnuss ja natürlich
war das der reeder der kosovo
sowohl gespielen zuerst in peking räte
kokosnuss welt der ritter der kokosnuss
ist aus
bei meinem film ich sehe das für eine
kacke als ob der sogar ein lego set von
sich hat ich nehme dieses video gerade
am 24 11 17 30 auf ich habe von einer
halben stunde ein video hochgeladen wo
ich das hier gemacht habe die pferde
schnauze kommt dahin denn genau so
jedenfalls habe ich die figur die ich
dort in dem spiel erschaffen habe vier
genannten einigen in den kommentaren das
bildschirme akinator sei was ich mir
nicht vorstellen kann weil als ob die
website nach einer halben stunde leute
da ein paar ich versuche jetzt einfach
mal viel zu finden mal eine figur trägt
keine weibliche kleidung sie wurde wie
youtube berühmt sie waren nicht bei
zweidabei sie ist kein mensch sie gehört
zur kontrakte
phil benutzt eigentlich nur seine
hässlichkeit meine figur ist
wahrscheinlich jünger als ich hat keine
wolle mit seinen nachbarn sie kommt
nicht aus einem modegeschäft eine figur
hat wahrscheinlich weiß graue haare wie
ist kein skelett sie ist
wahrscheinlich ein tier dies kein fährt
sie stammt aus einem spiel dies kein
pokémon wie wird von mir gespielt wie
ist nicht zwischen 16 und 18 ja sie hat
hörner
kevin
wie kommt er jetzt auf kevin die sag mal
einfach dass es kevin ist nur um kevin
wurde 5000 mal gespielt alles klar ich
habe jetzt gerade noch mal ein bisschen
weiter gesucht und jetzt kommen
chantal ich muss jetzt mal eben kurz
gucken wie auch schon mal gespielt wurde
sie wollen
ich habe ehrlich gesagt jetzt kein
interesse daran noch viel zu suchen
ich find's einfach nur mal wieder krass
wie wenig hobbys ihr habt und
19 fucking 404 mal ihr wisst was ich
meine wenn euch das video gefallen wie
so klatscht sich in letzter zeit immer
so dumm wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen das zeigt mir dass es euch
gefällt und dass die nada in bonn danke
für 300.000 place auf